cinéma avec la sortie mercredi prochain
de mariage un sujet universel traité sur
le ton de la comédie
quelques couples eux font le bilan le
temps d'un mariage dé vérité est bonne à
dire servi par une distribution
alléchante parce qu'elle deschamps
verdun puceau
le mariage est comme une ville assiégée
ceux qui sont dehors relire entrer ceux
qui sont dedans veulent en sortir dès
les premières répliques le ton est donné
ce mariage vous plonge au coeur de
l'institution sacré le temps d'un week
end et à travers cinq coups il y a ceux
qui se marient donc ceux qui se sont
mariés et ont divorcé ceux qui
s'interrogent
bref un week-end pendant lequel toutes
les crises et tous les doutes sont
permis spécule offert du film le
personnage d'alex et joué par jean
dujardin un faux cynique entre espoir et
désillusion que tu laisses pas tomber ça
fera toujours une belle ces deux
familles et les cadeaux tu peux les
rendre
je rigole il avait plusieurs couleurs à
jouer j'aime bien quand un personnage
est assez épais qu'il n'y a pas qu'une
seule couleur
on commence par une légèreté du cynisme
et puis on tombe
et puis on se redresse et puis c'est
plutôt agréable à jouer ça je tremble
depuis quatre mois et arrière marquer
sans qu'est ce que tu fais remarquer si
perdu cinq kilos
c'est écrit sur mon front je suis jeune
je suis belle et je te trompes alex mais
ça fait des années que tu me regardes
plus que 35 ans je suis un meuble
problèmes du couple pour moi c'est qu'à
un moment donné on ne se voit plus on
passe à côté des choses c'est que c'est
vrai qu'on veut pas tous les jours via
quelqu'un twins au quotidien on le voit
moche ball matin fripé bon et puis à un
moment donné et ben on fait plus
attention à l'autre des études et pierre
26 quelque chose train 15 ans sur ce
mariage n'épargne rien ni personne
ridicule à lavage de linge sale plein
d'enseignements pour tous les candidats
on était à lyon la tournée province il
ya une jeune fille qui est venue me voir
après la projection et qui m'a dit que
mariner dans trois mois dans la drôme
exactement que dans le film juste j
alors pas trop paniqués par le film elle
me dit non non pas du tout au contraire
maintenant je crois que je sais pourquoi
je me marre s'ils font tes 0,6 et
volonté vous en avez profité pour
refaire le jardin l'intérêt de mariage
ne réside pas dans le sujet mais dans le
traitement un mélange de férocité de
lucidité tendre f
il fait mouche et marié de source et
peut avoir le dernier mot avec une femme
à condition que ce soit oui
et